CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is a former
homeland security adviser to President
George W Bush Fran good morning morning
Charles question this morning is obvious
was this big firing because of how
comeon handled the emails and Secretary
Clinton or was it about the
investigation
having to do with a connection between
Trump transition team and the Russians
Charlie I'll tell you look it's clear
from the letter from rod Rosenstein the
current Deputy Attorney General who has
served two Republican now and two
Democratic presidents he goes back to
the Clinton administration where he
worked for me and it's quite clear from
his memo that this goes back to the
Clinton email I think the thing that
raises the Russia investigation is the
timing of it and the timing is
unfortunate I mean I would we have been
asking this question if it was if the
president had dismissed him on day one I
think from the administration's point of
view they gave him a chance to kind of
try and write the ship that is the FBI
that was in turmoil and after the
Clinton email investigation was
concluded and he hasn't done that and so
I think the timing of it is what raises
people's concern issues for many on both
sides I've heard it described as a
grotesque abuse of power is it that or
were there grounds for dismissal here in
your opinion you know III think it's uh
no this the language that's being used
is very inflammatory grotesque abuse of
power Nick Sounion right all this sort
of language is unfortunate this is a
hundred-year-old organization in the FBI
it is staffed by career men and women
who spend decades and devote themselves
to these investigations and by the way
Gail the very same agents who are
investigating this the Russia claims
yesterday are investigating today today
subpoenas are going out prosecutors are
involved they're grounds for dismissal
in your opinion well look I do think
under the under the Justice Department
guidelines about how you handle
investigations and public pronouncements
he violated those and many of the men
and women in the FBI were dismayed at
commis handling and very unhappy that he
pulled them into this political process
during the presidential election you
know Rosenstein memo cites Republican
and Democratic attorneys general and
deputies attorney general disagreeing
with his
handling of it and saying it was wrong
mistakes have consequences and I think
Jim call me is suffering I should tell
you I've known him for more than 30
years he is smart he is ethical he is
honest and so I think it's really
unfortunate that the way to see him go
and quickly the current director acting
director McCabe how long will he last
you know not clear you'd expect him to
stay until the the new nominee was
announced and confirmed the problem is
he too is caught up through his wife in
democratic politics and so he may only
be quite temporary had to be a better
way though to do it that he has learns
about it on the news Thank You Fran
Townsend very much